- Hi, it's Rie.
Today, I've been challenged
to take a popular food
and make it fancy.
Today's guest is Jordyn Jones.
She's a popular singer, content creator,
and a huge fan of "Make It Fancy."
Let's see what I'm making fancy today.
- Hey, Rie, it's Jordyn Jones.
I'm so excited to be a guest
today on "Make It Fancy."
I'm obsessed with Jolly Ranchers,
so I'm gonna put you up to the test
to make Jolly Ranchers fancy.
The blue raspberry Jolly
Ranchers are my favorite.
I cannot wait to go taste test soon,
and meet you, and make it fancy!
Jolly Rancher.
I have had this before.
I actually made a video.
I made a cream cookie
and I used the Jolly Rancher.
It's colorful and has a different flavor.
It's very versatile ingredient for baking.
Very strong aroma.
I'm always confused about
blue raspberry flavor
because raspberry, it's not blue.
There is watermelon, green apple,
blue raspberry, cherry.
Does it taste like watermelon?
Oh, yeah.
Sweeter, intense version of watermelon.
I ought to do grape.
Tastes like a grape candy.
It is a grape candy (chuckles).
These are very cool,
so I think I can make extra special today,
and as always, I'm
excited to make it fancy.
(jovial music)
Right, here's what I got:
strawberries, pears...
There are a bunch of pears.
Bear with me.
Pear with me.
Heavy cream, butter, eggs, and buttermilk.
From the pantry, I got vanilla extract,
baking soda, corn syrup, sugar,
flour, vegetable oil, salt,
white chocolate, and vodka.
All right, let's get started.
Make it fancy.
(intriguing music)
We have cherry-flavored Jolly Rancher.
Heat it in a pot, and melt completely.
- [Producer] Can you guess
when they were invented?
- 1940s.
- [Producer] 1949.
- 1949.
- [Producer] Rie, how are
you so good at history?
- I watch a lot of "Drunk History,"
and it's a cherry very informative show.
Once you don't see any visible candy bits,
I'm adding vodka,
and it's a lot of vodka: one cup.
(light up-tempo music)
(steam hisses)
All the Jolly Rancher
is melted into vodka.
Take off from the heat.
And cool-down, it takes about 15 minutes.
I'm adding one pound strawberry in a pot,
half cup of sugar.
You cook this until softened.
Mix it up.
It will take about 10 minutes,
but you don't want to burn on the bottom,
so constantly mixing.
Strawberry is cooked, nice and soft.
Transfer this in a blender.
Puree the strawberry and
sugar mixture in a blender.
Strain so it's nice and smooth,
adding Jolly Rancher vodka syrup.
Make it in total, two cups.
Next step, I'm going to
use four gelatin sheets.
Cover with cold water to bloom.
Make sure submerged completely.
And while it's blooming,
heat up vodka strawberry
Jolly Rancher puree.
I like this smell.
It's fresh strawberry,
it's not smell too artificial.
Sometimes, especially cherry flavor,
smell like a cough syrup.
Gelatin is soft and almost
look like a jellyfish.
Add this into my puree.
Whisk it, make sure it
completely dissolved.
Transfer to this pan.
Let is cool for room temperature,
and put it in a refrigerator.
Chill it about two to
four hours, until it sets.
So I have 25 Jolly Rancher.
Put it in the food processor.
Makes very unpleasant sound,
so hold your ears.
(blender whirs)
Ah!
Am I breaking this?
(blender whirs)
Shake it off.
And I just want to use
this big, pebble-sized one.
It's kind of like
old-timey looking for gold.
You are scooping gold from the sand.
So I'm gonna set this aside,
but we have plenty more things to do.
Using one stick of
room-temperature butter,
just whip it nicely.
200 gram of sugar, cream until fluffy.
I have three egg whites that
I am adding little by little,
scraping side of the bowl so
everything is mixed nicely.
Combine dry ingredients:
200 gram of flour,
1 1/4 teaspoon of baking soda,
half teaspoon of salt.
Lightly mix.
I have five ounces buttermilk,
quarter cup of vegetable oil,
one teaspoon vanilla extract.
So combine together,
and I'm going to alternate dry ingredients
and wet ingredients.
So everything is well-combined.
Add this Jolly Rancher pebbles.
It kind of squeak like a dinosaur.
Maybe that's just my hallucinating.
(Rie and producer laugh)
Sometimes I don't remember if it was dream
or if it's really happened to me.
Adding in a cake pan,
bake this cake in oven, 350 degree,
about 20 to 25 minutes.
Do the toothpick test,
and when toothpick comes
out clean, it's ready.
Bloom gelatin, two sheets.
Cover with cold water, 1
1/4 cup of heavy cream,
three tablespoon of corn syrup,
two teaspoon of vanilla.
Bring to simmer.
- [Produce] Do you feel
like a lot of the audience
is still making these?
- I don't think so.
(producer laughs)
I saw a lot of people making
first Lunchable episode,
Stove Top stuffing.
Brownie mix episode, I made a Swiss roll,
but I haven't seen people
made mirror glaze cake
for Eugene.
I think this one is also difficult too.
Came to a simmer.
Gelatin's melted, so I'm
adding the white chocolate.
Couverture chocolate has more cocoa butter
and melts more smoothly and evenly.
White chocolate is melted.
Take from the heat.
Add in the two cup of cold heavy cream,
and gently stir.
Cool down this to room temperature,
and put in a refrigerator,
and cool down about two hours.
Two hours later...
White chocolate mousse is
set in the refrigerator,
and I'm going to whip this until
it look like whipped cream.
I want to eat this.
Looks very good.
We use a good chocolate,
so I think this is a very nice texture.
This is ready.
Yes!
So I want to make sure the cake is flat,
so I'm going to cut a
little bit domey part
so it sits better.
- [Producer] Oh, wow!
Very nice.
- Smells good, too.
Smells very fruity.
Use this bowl.
It is the same size as my mold,
so I want to use this as a guide.
Jelly is completely set.
Still there.
Okay, so when you are
un-molding something very sticky
like jelly or pudding,
you hold it and spin yourself.
No.
(Rie and producer laugh)
No, it should work
'cause I've done that before.
(bright music)
Oh, I'm so dizzy!
(Rie and producer laugh)
Oh, no.
Yes!
And I have a glass bowl,
lined with plastic.
Add mousse, about 1/3.
So I'm going to use a
little bit smaller bowl
as a guide for the jelly.
And add mousse,
probably half height of the bowl.
Add the jelly.
Add more mousse.
Thick on the layer, it's done.
Top with Jolly Rancher fruitcake.
Tuck it in.
Freeze this six hours, to overnight,
but we have tub freezer,
and that saves some time.
One cup of sugar,
two cup of water,
and 10 Jolly Rancher.
It's a blue raspberry
flavor, Jordyn's favorite.
Cook over medium heat
and until Jolly Rancher is fully melted.
While it is cooking, I'm
going to slice some pears.
I'm using mandoline
'cause you can slice it even thickness
and very thin,
but mandoline is one of the
most dangerous kitchen tool.
I have cut my finger
before, so be careful.
Hold object like this, not like this
because you're gonna slice your finger,
and I think finger has more nerves,
so it's more painful.
And once it's getting difficult to hold,
I use kitchen towel so it
doesn't injure my finger.
I want to use just the middle portion,
where it just look like a slice of pear,
and I'm slicing two of them.
So you want to pick
through nice-looking part.
Those are all kind of cute.
I didn't cut my finger.
Oh, this kind of makes
me want to go vacation,
like clear, blue ocean.
(Rie laughs)
I want to swim in this.
Jolly Rancher is completely melted,
and I'm going to cook pears in this syrup,
about 15 minutes or until translucent.
So pretty.
It soaked up all the Jolly Rancher color.
Do the same process
with grapes, watermelon,
and green apple Jolly Rancher flavor,
and make Jolly Rancher-soaked pears.
Dry and remove extra moisture.
Put the piece of paper towel over.
Put this in a silicone baking mat.
Bake this at 200 degree, about two hours.
And moving on to the next step.
We have Jolly Rancher mousse cake.
Remove plastic.
And I have hot water here,
so frozen cake release easily.
Remove the mold.
And I have Jolly Rancher-soaked pears,
and I'm going to decorate.
And I'm using simple
syrup to the cake part.
It will stick a little better.
And you want to stick these
pears, over-wrapping each other.
It is beautiful!
I'm so happy how it's turned out.
It's almost look like a stained glass.
When you are just free-styling,
just think about balance of the color,
and if it doesn't stick together,
you can use simple syrup,
and glue to the cake.
This is kind of look like a pickle.
We're gonna heavy on the blue color
since it's her favorite.
Once you come to this mousse part,
it is already wet, so
it's very easy to stick.
And we are done!
(whimsical music)
Jolly Rancher pear
mousse cake, very fancy.
Let's see what Jordyn thinks.
(cheerful music)
Hi!
- Oh, my gosh!
You're real!
- I made Jolly Rancher
mousse cake for you.
(Rie laughs)
- I'm not watching from
my phone right now.
- Yeah!
Wow!
- When was the first episode?
- Like a long time ago.
- Oh, wow!
- But now, I am like,
there's an episode that
drops, I'm the first view.
How Would You Make It Fancy fan.
- You are over 21, right?
- I am.
Okay.
(Rie laughs)
- I am.
I don't drink, though.
- Okay.
- But I know how you are.
(Rie and Jordyn laugh)
- You're a true fan.
And when I made this cake,
I didn't think about cutting it.
(Jordyn laughs)
So, I might struggle.
- We're here for it.
It looks beautiful!
- Just for you!
- Wow!
- [Rie and Jordyn] Cheers!
- Mm.
- Mm...
Mm...
- Mm.
- Mm...
- That is the blue raspberry you like.
- Yes!
You made them fancy.
- Yay!
If I ask you to dance,
can you make a special dance for us?
- Oh, my God, yes!
(Rie laughs)
So you we can do like,
make it fancy!
- [Rie] Okay.
- And we have the make it fancy,
like the full-out version.
(Rie laughs)
- Okay, I like the second one,
but I don't think I can do it.
- So you go diagonal, all the way up.
- Uh-huh.
- And then here.
Uh-huh.
- And then down.
- Okay.
- Or we could even just go,
up and down.
- Okay, okay.
Yes, yes!
- [Rie and Jordyn] Make it fancy!
- Did I do that? (laughs)
(cheerful music)